when I was in secondary school I was
actually interested very much in
literature but I was also very much
interested in mathematics and my teacher
mathematics I liked him very much
I think it's about the only one I liked
and I was at the secondary school but
and so I had a very good relation with
him and I was not a bad student so he
pushed me to enter Polytechnic school
for engineering well this was because
also partly because engineering in
Belgium requires an entrance examination
which is very hard actually three places
if you wish the diploma of secondary
school you don't have to do secondary
school if you succeed at exam so and so
he prepared me for that exam that they
did so I was an engineer now being an
engineer I realized that I don't want to
be an engineer and but I was an engineer
so that gave me I realized by being a
union that that what interests me is not
so much the application of things but
the way the function so that's why I got
interested in physics in this version
from the manga physics so after having
engineer I got sufficient money because
I could I had a job at the University
and I studied physics afterwards and
then my PhD and then went to the United
States and met horbet part
and so that's in a short and this story